g6  but okay this is  completely hopeless yeah  queen h4 and if your queen queen takes  g4 and your king just runs no perpetual  so no queen sacrifices and it's hard to  imagine a perpetual for black hair  but probably he will even play rookie  four no i mean you think that would be  super pragmatic pragmatic prague if he  goes repeat four yeah i mean he did not  want to clean before he doesn't want to  calculate so i'm expecting yeah lookie  for him he goes for it yeah he goes he's  giving no chances at all he doesn't even  want to allow one check on g4 no and  this is right i mean we lit the time on  the clock uh  calculate as little as possible yeah  because if if you start calculating you  can blunder something  and okay where is the there is the  stalemate because the g7 oh yeah bishop  e6 check no stamina thank you very much  and  that is it  grug wins his second game as well  against yantristov duda